Hey youtubers it’s Charlie since I did a
villains power ranking for Arrow this year
I wanted to do one for The Flash.
I’m doing videos for both, so hopefully
I’ll be able to do this kind of thing all
year.
Both Arrow and The Flash have only shot about
half their seasons so far.
And the flash hasn’t officially been picked
up for a full season.
So there are still a ton of villains both
shows can bring on.
I might have to revise this list in February
when everything comes back from break.
Since everything they’re doing is adapted
from a comic book I’ll try to not include
too many spoilers, but I’ll be explaining
each of these villains and their origin stories.
So just a heads up.
Starting with number 10 - Girder who we’ll
meet on the show as Tony Woodward
He’s being played by Greg Finley on the
show and we’ll meet him in episodes 6 and
7.
In the comics he’s a normal blue collar
steel worker who gets thrown into a vat of
molten steel.
The vat contained scraps of metal from star
labs experiments.
The scraps convert his body into living Iron
giving him super strength and super durability.
He becomes a walking tank.
But because he’s iron, he can still rust.
He was part of the appropriately titled Iron
Heights storyline in the comics, so that might
be how the tv series uses him.
When people in the canon refer to Iron Heights,
they’re usually talking about Iron Heights
penitentiary, the big prison in Central City.
The show might change his backstory just a
little but his powers will be the same.
Number 9 - Plastique who we’ll meet on the
show as Bette Sans
She’s being played by Kelly Frye and we’ll
meet her in Episode 5.
The character actually appeared in the Firestorm
Comics first.
She was at times in love with Captain Atom
and his enemy.
And eventually she was even part of the Suicide
Squad.
So she’s one of the few easy crossover characters.
I know everyone’s asking about a suicide
squad show but I’ll mention something about
that at the end of the video.
Because she’s a Firestorm-centric character,
she might get tied up in a Robbie Amell heavy
episode.
He’s playing Firestorm on the show.
Her ability allows her to project explosive
force from her body.
So it might look like a concussion wave for
anyone that played Knights of the Old Republic.
She was originally a suicide bomber in the
comics so they might change her backstory
on the show too.
8 - Killer Frost because this could be potentially
super spoilery I’m just going to give an
extra warning with this tag.
You can just jump forward in the video till
you don’t see this little tag if you want.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay, here we go.
Killer Frost is Caitlin Snow, on the show
that character is being played by Danielle
Panabaker.
She is one of Barry’s friends.
So it’s possible something big could happen
to make her turn against Team Flash.
Her powers are pretty simple, she’s like
a female iceman.
The reason I put her above the others is because
the smarter villains tend to be the more dangerous
ones.
Okay, spoilers over, Number 7 - General Wade
Eiling who’s being played by Clancy Brown
He’s done a billion cartoon superhero voices,
you guys will really like him.
He’s just an awesome actor in general.
His character in the comics is actually responsible
for the creation of Captain Atom, so hopefully
we’ll see him on the show eventually.
They’ve done a lot of different things with
the Wade character in the comics and cartoons.
He’s transferred his consciousness into
another body, he’s injected himself with
Super Soldier Serum.
On the show he’ll just be a sinister military
man throwing his weight around.
But it’s possible they could make him all
hulked out.
He’s like the DC Version of General Ross
from the Marvel Universe, so I don’t think
they need to give him powers to make him a
threat.
Number 6 - Simon Stagg who will be played
by William Sadler
We’re into mastermind slash big villain
territory now.
As the list gets higher, the villains get
smarter and more dangerous.
Simon Stagg is a super rich businessman in
the comics, so think of him as a Lex Luthor
type.
He doesn’t have special powers of his own,
but he has unlimited money and is really good
at manipulating people.
I’m interested to see if in the show he
tries to hire any or all of the Rogues to
take down The Flash.
There’s a lot more cool stuff in the comics,
his character is also kind of responsible
for the creation of Metamorpho.
So that’s another character that The Flash
could bring on someday.
Or they could be laying groundwork for The
Outsiders in a future season.
Arrow’s already doing Katana this year,
so they’re part of the way there already.
Number 5 - Heat Wave who we’ll meet on the
show as Mick Rory
He’s being played by Dominic Purcell, one
of the many Prison Break alums Arrow and The
Flash have cast.
Because they’re doing powers on the show,
I think they’ll go with the new 52 version
of the character, but give him the arc from
Flash Rebirth.
Before the new 52 reboot, he had to use heat
guns to make flame and after the reboot he
became a full blown meta human.
In the comics, Heat Wave has always been one
of the less dependable Rogues.
So I think they cast Dominic Purcell because
he’s known for playing really powerful characters
that aren’t always the sharpest knife in
the drawer.
He and Captain Cold have a very toxic relationship
as far as partners go, but Captain Cold is
definitely the brains of that Operation.
4 - The Clock King from Arrow
Robert Knepper is going to be a crossover
villain in episode 7.
The Clock King will show up in Central City.
Because episode 7 is also the episodes Girder
shows up in, it’s possible the two villains
could be connected somehow.
Robert Knepper is also of course one of the
many Prison Break Alums, which leads me to
Number 3 - Captain Cold who we’ll meet on
the show as Leonard Snart
He’s being played by Wentworth Miller from
Prison Break.
He’ll be in the fourth episode.
Which is one episode after Robbie Amell debuts
as Firestorm.
They really aren’t wasting any time rolling
out the big guns this season.
Captain Cold will probably be a similar situation
to Heat Wave, they’ll give him his metahuman
abilities like in the new 52 comics but they’ll
be using classic elements of his backstory.
The character isn’t straight up evil, he’s
more a villain of circumstance.
The Flash has been able to reason with him
at times and the other Rogues have turned
on him for going against them.
Wentworth Miller isn’t really known for
playing villains, so re-watch some of his
prison break episodes of you want to get a
vibe for what he might be like on The Flash.
I know a lot of you are asking whether or
not The Flash will do his sister Glider.
It’s possible, in the new 52 comics she
shows up after they wind up in prison.
So she might get referenced if they don’t
cast an actor as her character.
I’m really excited to see Captain Cold on
the show.
He’ll be one of the better antagonists.
Number 2 - Professor Zoom
Yes I do think Professor Zoom will be a part
of the show somehow.
If you’ve seen the first episode, please
use spoiler tags when commenting.
You can’t do a Flash show without the biggest
Flash villain ever, especially since they’re
sticking to the comics.
So I don’t consider talking about Professor
Zoom to be a spoiler.
At the TCAs, Greg Berlanti and Andrew Kriesberg
said we would learn about the big villain
before the mid-season finale.
So he’ll start appearing fairly quickly.
No idea what that ends up looking like.
But again, you can always read Flash Rebirth.
Of all the Reverse Flashes, he’s the most
recognizable, but he’s not the most powerful.
Which leads me to my number 1 villain on The
Flash this season - Zoom
Yes, I think we’ll see more than one Reverse
Flash.
They will be two different people.
I have my theories about how that’s going
to happen, but just to avoid super spoilers
I’ll wait till we get into episodes to talk
in depth about it.
If you think about the characters they’ve
already announced, you’ve seen the Pilot
Episode and you read the comics and know how
Zoom becomes Zoom, think about which character
on the show that might end up being.
I’ll give you a hint, it’s the one character
that hasn’t been doing any press and hasn’t
been going to any of the big conventions.
Let me know though, which of the Rogues are
you most excited to see and do you think they’ll
make any prison break jokes if they appear
on screen together?
I know the big question you have is how close
to the comics they’re sticking and Berlanti
and Kriesberg who are running the show said
that they’ll stick very close to the storyline
of Flash Rebirth with a few minor adjustments.
Since I’m doing an Arrow Hero Power Ranking
Video Next Week I’ll do one for the Flash
too.
If you’re new to my channel and you like
talking about Arrow and The Flash please subscribe
to get everything.
We’d love to have you on the team.
I’ll be doing videos for all the DC Comics
TV Shows, I’m really excited about everything.
It’s going to be a lot of fun.
Right now click here for my breakdown of the
new Arrow Season 3 Clip and click here to
learn about the Arrow Flash Crossover Episode.
Thanks for watching, now let’s all high
five and meet back up for some Star Wars tomorrow!